[Music]
via live and on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
so
[Music]
we will make emission trading work not
only for energy generation and
industry but also for transport and
for buildings carbon must have its price
because nature cannot pay the price any
longer
nature cannot pay the price any longer
that was european commission president
ursula van der lyon speaking earlier
today at president biden's virtual
global climate summit
welcome back to this very special earth
day edition of take a break i'm tim
stenovec in new york
well the modern age's most iconic piece
of clothing a pair of blue jeans
is also one of the most environmentally
harmful to make
billions of pairs are sold every year
from stylishly distressed to faded
vintage
styles that look worn out from hours in
the sun or repeated washing
are almost never so they've achieved
that effect right off the production
line from toxic chemicals mixed with
water
enrique sia the ceo and co-founder of
genologica has spent the past
26 years developing production methods
aimed
at reducing that pollution here's his
story
fashion is about emotion making you feel
sexy
so we cannot develop a product that
protect the planet
but compromise the look
i started genealogia 25 years ago
i come from a textile family
denim jeans are the iconic garment
everybody has a jeans in their wardrobe
to produce one gene
we contaminate 100 liters of water
20 percent of the water
that contaminates the river of the
planets are
at least coming from textile and
apparently industry
but i decided to create the company to
solve this problem
the first technology that we develop is
laser is
using the energy of a laser to distress
the genes to
reproduce the effect of the past of the
time before this was
known with a lot of chemistry the second
technology
also we are using the air to produce the
stonewashed look
and with both technologies together we
reduce
80 of the water consumption but our
ambition was zero waste
so then the third one is nano bubbles
in one centimeter you have one million
bubbles
and these bubbles like a cloth are
transporting chemistry
into the garments and with that
we reduce the amount of water from
hundred liters
to only 10 liters so then we decide to
create h20
and that works like a kind of backpack
take
the water clean the water and put the
water into the system
again so the combinations of four
technologies
allowed us to produce genes with
zero water sheet of waste and without
contaminating the rivers of our planet
today 35 of the genes that are produced
in the world
use our technologies levi strauss lee
tommy hilfier calvin h m dolce gabanna
or dsl are using our technologies
during the 90s on the production ran
away
to countries where labor was
cheap because these countries at that
time didn't have regulations and
everything was possible you
you were able to produce destroying the
the planet
and i'm sure that in the next five years
10 15 of the production is going to come
back to europe
it's going to come back to the us it's
going to come back to japan
it's going to come back near the
consumer
[Music]
in 2018 we create the first
plant in the history of textiles in the
desert of nevada
in a place where water was not available
that don't use water
and cannot contaminate water it was
unbelievable the achievement of all our
dreams
the main thing to make sure that
designers
are happy with the results and i will
say that it's not only happening
we are creating and providing tools to
the designers
to make their dreams a reality
but in a way that they
do not contaminate our planet
[Music]
a big thank you to mark hall and
julianne wilkinson for that one
well coming up a 16 year old
environmentalist in uganda
plans to plant one million new trees in
the country's forest
we're back in two minutes with a little
bit of good news this
is take a break
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
concrete action is needed
we need such action
at a high speed on a large scale
and with a global scope
we in india are doing our part
that was india's prime minister narendra
modi speaking earlier today at president
biden's virtual
global climate summit welcome back to
this special earth day edition of take a
break
i'm tim stenovec now it's time for a
little bit of quick take good news on
this earth day
in the forest of uganda bare patches of
land like this are a common sight
forest cover here has depleted from 24
percent to just 8
since the 1990s it's a problem all over
the world
according to global forest watch but one
young
activist is fighting back
sixteen-year-old
leah namaguerwa has made it her mission
to replant the forests of her nation
she's planning on putting more than one
million trees back in the ground within
a decade
her birthday each year is the motivator
and leah's initiative is proving an
inspiration
far beyond the borders of uganda she
uses her social media power to encourage
other youngsters to regularly plant
trees
as they celebrate their birthdays her
target of 1 million trees is still a
long way off
but with every new planting more and
more people
join in well that's going to do it for
quick take this hour on earth day you
can always check out the latest stories
at bloomberg.com also check out
bloomberg green
our section dedicated to bloomberg
coverage of the climate
you can also follow us
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're now in this situation where
climate change is an
existential risk to our future economy
and our way of life while the us
certainly has an uphill climb
uh i think it's it has a lot of support
from across the country
and is really in an important way
centering climate action
at the core of economic recovery we will
raise our radar to search
of any technology which can contribute
to
force to achieve this goal so we will be
more investing
to dc and the ventures having 70
trillion
of uh private capital coming behind that
zero which is what's being announced
today
uh is the type of momentum the world
needs
good afternoon and welcome to bloomberg
quick take where we bring you today's
top news and break down how it
intersects with the world of business
today's earth day and over the next hour
we're going to hear from leaders across
industries and regions on their efforts
to fight climate change and mobilize
others to do the same
good afternoon everyone it's thursday
april 22nd i'm tim stenovec in new york
let's get going
[Music]
good afternoon everyone well president
biden has brought together world leaders
for a virtual summit on climate change
the president
made a new commitment to cut u.s fossil
fuel emissions
up to 52 percent by 2030. that marks a
return to global climate efforts after
four years of withdrawal under president
trump
in order to reach that goal
transportation secretary pete boudej
says congress needs to pass the american
jobs plan
that president biden has proposed
this is a whole of government and whole
of society efforts so
no one piece of legislation even an
enormously important one like the jobs
plan
is going to be the whole story
especially because there are things like
the
technologies that haven't yet fully
developed like we were talking about
with
aviation fuel a lot of change coming to
how people get around that will by 2030
look quite different
with me now is congressman john
garamendi a democrat representing
california's third district it's in
northern california congressman thanks
so much for taking the time
what does congress agree on when it
comes to the environment when it comes
to climate change do democrats and
republicans see eye to eye
on anything
the answer is no and that's the tragedy
here
and that's the problem for this entire
planet is that
we are not able to develop a consensus
within the congress to really do the
things that are necessary
to address climate change and it is a
structural change as
secretary budeck alluded to it's a
structural change
away from fossil fuels it can be done
there is no doubt that it can be done
but it's going to take
government to lead and that means we
have to change the incentives
so that people and industry are willing
and
financially able to
green technologies and we have to
eliminate the incentives that exist
today for the fossil fuel industry
particularly the petroleum industry
which has an
enormous for 120 years of
government incentives to pump more oil
and gas out of the ground
okay so let's start with the incentives
that you that you want to see what do
you think the federal government needs
to do
in order to encourage companies to make
these changes
that would slow down a climate change
well first of all we need a carbon tax
and it can be a fully refundable carbon
tax or any other thing but you've got to
put a pricing mechanism
into this so that the uh system that is
the economic system will respond to the
price
signal that carbon fuels are
expensive secondly we need to provide
the
financial incentives and these are
subsidies of various kinds
for battery storage and i'm not just
talking about chemical batteries but
other kinds of batteries and there are
many different ways we can store
energy and secondly fully develop and
put in place the green renewable
technologies
uh congressman you're from northern cal
well you live in northern california
you've been there for
a very long time and i'm wondering how
you've seen
climate change play out in your district
and what changes
you've seen and and i'm wondering
specifically if you could get some of
your republican colleagues to go back to
your district with you
what you would show them to show them
that this is
something dire that needs to be
addressed
i would show them a fire season it is no
longer six or seven months of the year
but
but 12 months of the year i'll show them
communities that are gone because
they've been totally destroyed
by wildfires i will show them a national
forest
of which more than half of the forest is
gone
i would show them a continuing drought
back in 1977 when i started my ranching
operation that was a one-year
drought and it was devastating we now
have droughts occurring
once every two three four years uh
interrupted by a wet season that is a
devastating wet season
literally a uh a tsunami
of water coming out of the sky and so
we're getting this
extreme weather we're getting hot
come to california in the summertime
northern california which used to have a
few
days over 100 degrees now we have months
over 100 degrees uh it is a
very serious problem and by the way i'll
show you tropical diseases that never
existed in california
that are there now i'm in new york now
but i grew up in california and i
absolutely know what you're talking
about i've seen it firsthand my parents
are still there
uh and yeah it's it's happening but i
wonder why this is a
a partisan issue why do you think this
is something that goes down party lines
because there are plenty of republicans
who live in areas of the country uh that
have been significantly affected and
severely affected by climate change
i i don't know i i guess we all
in one way or another we adopt a
position and we're unwilling to change
it
even in the face of uh drought and
calamitous fires and the like we're
unwilling to change uh it becomes a
mantra
a mantra that we've come to use to
advance our own political careers
a mantra that we used uh in the face of
devastating facts unwilling to change
you know and i suppose the republicans
will say the same about us that
all we want to do is to shut down the
petroleum industry
we're not interested in jobs i heard it
earlier this morning
from one of our colleagues about the uh
the pipelines that were that
biden shut down and so
they talk about jobs but on the job side
it is a
fact that the green technologies
actually are going to be the jobs of the
future not the petroleum industry not
the coal
i industries talking to one of my
colleagues from west virginia
and he said we're going to be down to
just two
congressional districts he said just
years ago we had six
and i said population is leaving he said
yes
population is leaving for a variety of
reasons there is a transition occurring
here in america and around the world
away from fossil fuels
the faster we do that the faster we move
to the green tech
technologies to the renewables to the
way in which we can store energy the
grid systems
all of those things the faster we will
recover and if we do this
with american technology and make it in
america
which is an absolutely a critical part
of this transition
not relying upon china for our wind
turbines but
rather making it in america we will
create those jobs we'll create the
opportunities
and we will be able to attack the
climate christs
congressman i want to end talking about
that renewable energy today
kathy wood of arc invest along with
tesla's elon musk
uh and jack dorsey of twitter and square
um
they are supporting a claim that bitcoin
can actually help the planet by
encouraging
more solar projects and thereby reducing
their cost
we should note that renewable energy
costs are going down
regardless of bitcoin but i'm wondering
if you have any thoughts on that
i i think we need to separate these
issues
we need not to bring into the debate
other complexities uh the it is
complex enough to put in place
the financial incentives to go green
that we must do if we do that these
other pieces that are
on the outside of it uh will come into
place
how do you finance it how do you do
these
i don't know new technologies or new
financial technologies
but we do know that we must do it
it's a fact we're right now we've got an
armed services hearing going on
we know that our major military bases
cannot survive in the climate of
tomorrow
the sea level rises is an extraordinary
problem for the world's biggest
uh naval base and that's norfolk
in virginia they're going to have to
have waiters to get
to the ships right and you go beyond
that so the resiliency of the military
and right now one of the things that i'm
doing
is to force the military to reduce this
energy consumption
by going green by going with hybrid
vehicles
all of these things are possible we need
to force
our systems we cannot just stand by
and think it's going to evolve it has to
be forced upon
the american economy and when we do it
the military will be better off
because the most dangerous thing for the
military is the transportation
of fuel congressman we're going to have
to leave it there
thank you so much for taking the time
democratic representative john
garamendi of california congressman
thanks so much we appreciate you joining
us thank you one quick take on earth day
today
well in the fight against climate change
young people are taking the lead
pushing for change advocating for
climate literacy and demanding more from
world leaders
one of the organizations leading the
fight is the sunrise movement
it's a youth movement to stop climate
change and create millions of jobs in
the process
they've participated in sit-ins and
climate strikes across the country
and in 2020 they contacted over 6.5
million voters in the primaries and in
the general election helping create the
largest youth turnout
in history sunrise movement national
spokesperson lily gardner joins me now
from lexington
lexington kentucky lily thanks so much
for being here it is so great to have
you on the show
i want to get your reaction to what
we're hearing from world leaders so far
today
is what you're hearing enough
absolutely so i think president biden in
particular's commitment
to cutting emissions by 2030
has really been lauded as a start
but we know that it's not enough right
and i think that
if he wants to earn the title of
international climate leader
then we need to think about the science
that is so clearly telling us that we
have to
we have we have to cut global emissions
um in half by 2030 and we know that
the us is the country with the most
historical responsibility and the
greatest economic capacity to do that
and so we need to be bold with our
vision and
i think a real part of that is going
bolder than just saying
we're going to cut in half by 2030 and
thinking
thinking about what more we can achieve
i'm wondering the best way to do this
though does it does it come
from electing electing members of of
congress
and other elected officials who are in
line with your cause
as the sunrise movement tried to do
in the latest election or does more need
to be done
i think that's certainly one component
right electing
officials who are in line with the
vision for a green new deal
is certainly going to support massive
government
investment that we know is necessary and
we know that president biden can be a
real leader in this moment
and stick to the campaign promises we
fought for and he has made
including things like the civilian
climate corps to make these realities a
possible
or possibility even sooner than the next
election cycle
what is the best way to communicate
these issues because i think that
you know a lot of people can can think
about
it's it's hard because i think for a lot
of people climate change
is one of those things that they can
ignore and
and not actually think affects their
day-to-day life and
and that certainly changes when we have
natural disasters and to what extent
they are
connected to a changing climate um
scientists can
debate about that and specific disasters
there but what is the best way to
communicate this to
to young people right now to make them
care about something uh
that they have trouble visualizing
perhaps
sure so i think in many ways young
people are a generation
that has had to grapple with the impacts
of the climate crisis for our entire
lives
but when i think more broadly about how
we talk about the climate crisis
i think about my home in appalachia
which has been so
devastated by the impacts of the coal
and fossil fuel industries
and yet the i think the dominant
narrative
is one that jobs are in
really in tension with the possibility
of stopping climate change and that
we are fundamentally not aligned on our
values when i think that is
really not the case and so often i start
these conversations
whether it be with young people people
who might not be
politically aligned with me or just an
ordinary person in my community
from the base of a value like everyone
having access to a good dignified job
that doesn't force them
to choose between their health and
putting food on the table
lily you mentioned coal and fossil fuels
so i want to get your reaction to what
greta tunberg said
earlier today testifying at a u.s
congressional hearing on fossil fuel
subsidies she said quote
we have to end fossil fuel subsidy stop
new exploration and extraction
completely divest from fossil fuels and
keep the carbon
in the ground what are your thoughts on
that do you agree with her
absolutely i think that's spot on and i
think that
in that process we really hold the
workers of
fossil fuel industries through con yeah
through ideas like adjust transition
supporting whole communities and
transitioning away from these economies
that were based on extractive industries
into ones that support care work and
perhaps renewable energy jobs
and these myriad things through programs
like the civilian climate corps
as you saw i just spoke with congressman
garamendi of northern california a
district that has been
hard hit by climate change drought fires
you name it um
he said though that republicans and
democrats don't come anywhere close to
agreeing
when it comes what to do to what to do
about the climate
are you hopeful though
i think i could not do this work if i
wasn't hopeful
in the power of our communities that
being said
republicans have chosen time and again
that they are going to be the party of
violence and the party that is
going to condemn both our futures and
our presence and the real experiences of
environmental injustice
that are happening across the united
states as we speak
and so i think while i'm hopeful when i
have conversations with fellow
organizers
i also know that it's going to take a
lot
including right the abolition of the jim
crow filibuster
and real leadership from president biden
in a bold and divisive way for us to
overcome
this entrenched party divide and and
pass legislation that's going to make a
real
impact on people's lives lily gardner we
are going to have to
leave it there that's lily gardner
sunrise movement national spokesperson
lily thanks so much for taking the time
really appreciate you joining us on
earth day thank you for having me
now we don't want to bury the lead on
the rest of the day's top news so here
are some climate stories we do not want
you to miss
on earth day bloomberg has learned that
the biden administration will restore
california's power
to limit auto emissions it's a shift
that will lead to tougher requirements
across much of the u.s
two trump-era policies limited
california's ability to set ambitious
vehicle standards and kathy woods arc
investment
has new research that says bitcoin
mining isn't as environmentally damaging
as some
claim it is often criticized as a highly
energy intensive activity but arc says
bitcoin mining could encourage
investment in solar energy systems
and energy providers could play the
arbitrage between electricity prices
and bitcoin prices we should note that
the trends in the clean energy industry
are already happening and the prices
are for renewables are going down and
entries for elon musk's carbon removal
competition opened today he announced
the competition a few months back
and the huge 100 million dollars of
prize money that's up for grabs
even though the competition opens up
today winners won't get their prize
money for four years
three winners will be named for three
separate prizes 50 million
20 million dollars in 10 million dollars
that's happening
on earth day 2025 so get to work about
the competition musk said quote carbon
negativity
not neutrality this is not a theoretical
competition whatever it takes
time is of the essence you can always
learn more about these stories and stay
up to date on today's news at
bloomberg.com
well coming up next the fashion industry
has grown into one of the top
contributors to global carbon emissions
so what's being done to slow down fast
fashion
we're talking to an expert in the
industry on ways that the fashion
industry can shift
we're back in two minutes this is take a
break
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
canada is now on track to blow past
our old target of 30 reduction below
2005 levels last december
we strengthened our climate plan to
reduce more emissions
including with a world-leading price on
pollution
well that of course was canadian prime
minister justin trudeau speaking earlier
today
at u.s president joe biden's climate
summit on his country's push to lower
emissions welcome back to this very
special earth day edition of take a
break i'm tim steinebeck in new york
it's time now for quick take by the
numbers it's where we let the data tell
the story
this afternoon's number is 10 percent in
2019 the fashion industry was
responsible for 10
of annual global carbon emissions more
than all
international flights and maritime
shipping combined
at this pace the fashion industry's
greenhouse gas emissions
will surge more than 50 percent by 2030
that's according to the united nations
environment program so get this
to make one pair of jeans it takes about
7 500
liters of water that's equivalent to the
amount of water that the average person
drinks
over a period of seven years
mind-boggling
well our next guest has seen first-hand
how the fashion industry affects the
environment
and the people involved she's toured the
world as a celebrity stylist working
with artists like drake nicki minaj and
lionel richie
and now she has her very own shop in los
angeles that works to bring socially and
environmentally conscious fashion
to the masses founder and creative
director of gallery la
dashelle mckillion joins us now to shell
thank you so much for
taking the time i want to talk about
what goes into
making a garment you just heard me talk
about the the staggering amount of water
that it takes to make a pair of jeans
but i still think there's this
disconnect between what we wear and the
impact that it has on the environment
that's so much different than
what we think about when we drive in a
car or or you know
steve smog in l.a or get on an airplane
why is that
yes i agree and i mean i found out that
through just normal consumerism
we don't know how garments are made
fashion has a huge supply chain
from you know just think of the cotton
that's grown
in our soil to that cotton going to
a factory that's creating fabric to that
fabric then
creating a garment to that garment that
you're wearing
and a lot of the impact actually that
fashion has and the
items that we're buying happens after we
actually buy the garment so it's how we
take care of the garment
what are we doing after we dispose of it
all these lead to a big environmental
impact that just kind of adds up
so what should we be doing what should
we be doing as consumers when it comes
to
understanding what we're buying what
we're wearing and how we're
taking care of it through its life cycle
yes
you know for me i think it's about
slowing down
i really think it comes to self
especially in america we're bombarded
with
so much marketing of buying products
that we actually
don't need so once you slow down and you
can actually ask
ask yourself do i need this do i need to
like just
impulse buy this item right now
and so beyond that impulse buy you can
start to look at a brand's website that
you might be
going on and being more intentional you
can see see
what the item what the material is look
for eco-friendly fabrics
look for recycled fabrics and processes
look to see if these brands have ethical
factories
look to see you know are they using zero
waste in their
production um there's so many questions
that we can begin to
ask as consumers and i think that once
you slow down from
that you know i gotta buy buy buy buy
you know just being at this moment you
can actually explore different options
you know there's rentals where you know
we have like
weddings and you just go ahead and you
know buy
that one thing that you're just gonna
wear once and then you
donate it but you could rent that item
instead of
buying and keep extending fashion's life
cycle
their swap you can go to swaps inside
and swap with friends now there's thread
up where you can
get items that would normally be
discarded at just very
low prices so you know you i think again
it comes to the slowing down and there's
a lot of options
dashell how do you do this so affordably
you mentioned some some great options
there
especially for secondhand clothes but if
i think about this from the perspective
of buying a new garment
there are companies that you can buy
from that have transparency right
patagonia is one that comes to mind but
those clothes are
are really expensive and one thing that
we have seen with the rise of
globalization
has meant lower prices for consumers
uh and that's really what fast fashion
has been and it hasn't been great for
the environment but the incentives to me
don't seem like they're right because
that stuff is so cheap so how do you
bring the prices down
for environmentally friendly garments
yes
i mean again i don't want to say that
all companies that are
saying they're environmentally friendly
are ethical but it comes down to
the garment workers are they being paid
fair wages
for the island out there
beyond that there's so much
more that goes into the actual making of
a garment
and that we can ask consumers can ask
questions about so tell me how you're
doing this uh
as a celebrity stylist and and how
you're doing this at gallery la
yes so when i was a celebrity stylist
that's how i
first realized fashion's impact on our
planet i was traveling places
and just seeing like so much pollution
that was clothing
it was shoes the factories how our
things were made
and as a celebrity stylist you put
something on a celebrity and people just
buy it because it's on a celebrity
and then you know discard of it so i
realized my own impact
and really that's where gallery lay was
born is because i was looking for
fashion brands that were producing their
clothing responsibly
and within a lot of research i
came to see that okay if sustainable
fashion is so hard to understand
we're not gonna buy it it has to be cool
it has to be easy to understand so we
develop the sustainable value badge
system
that really makes it easy for people to
shop their values
so everything that we carry at gallery
la is ethically made
meaning our brands work with their
factories
they know that workers are getting paid
fair wages they know they
have safe working conditions so that's
like the main criteria
and then beyond that brands use
eco-friendly
materials they use recycled materials
and up-cycle processes vegan materials
eliminating all animal and animal
by-products
they work with artisans all around the
world
to you know produce their items so
instead
of us getting rid of these traditions we
can actually embrace
traditions like hand weaving and natural
dyeing processes
to keep the global economy afloat right
and that's how we do it and i'm curating
each and every piece
so everything that we carry i'm hand
selecting
i want it to be in you know your closet
for years to come it's based on quality
it's based on design
it's based on you know timelessness
dashell i i we don't have much time left
but i want to talk about something that
that you have touched on
uh the challenges of starting a
sustainably focused company as a black
woman
um one of your latest initiatives
targets this specifically
tell us what gallery la's goodie bag
initiative is
yeah so last june amid all the
unrest that was happening you know i
just felt
that as a black woman there was so much
more that even i could do in this space
because to be honest starting a
sustainable fashion business and
the vision that i had and like taking to
venture capitalists and just sharing
this idea
i got so much pushback and
you know i didn't realize oh maybe it's
because of a black woman i'm just like
okay they're not ready for it so i just
kind of chugged along
but so often you know as a black
business owner
we are really just you know trying to
make it happen and with the pandemic
there were so many black businesses
struggling
and so in sustainable fashion and
wellness
and clean beauty there's so many black
brands
that just are not getting the attention
they are not
you know being pushed to the front of
you know big retailers that you would
like to see so at gallery la i developed
the goody bag to just make it easy for
you to discover
sustainable brands in the clothing
wellness and clean beauty industries
and support these businesses during this
time because they have
amazing products and it's about time
that we
you know like spread it yeah
it is about time gallery la founder and
creative director deshelle mckinley and
dashell thank you so much for taking the
time and for joining us
on earth day today well coming up next
is the u.s poised to become the global
leader of climate policy
we'll be back in two minutes to discuss
where biden's agenda lies when it comes
to other countries this is take a break
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers and industry experts
via live and on-demand webinars only
from
bloomberg start exploring
to see what's moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change in
the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to this very special earth
day edition of take a break i'm tim
steineveck in new york
well president biden convening 40 world
leaders in a virtual summit intended to
demonstrate renewed american resolve to
fight climate change
bloomberg's climate policy reporter
jennifer dilowy has been following it
all and
joins me now from washington dc to
discuss hey jennifer
it's always great to have you on the
show what are your sources saying about
biden's climate pledge
is it ambitious enough to make the u.s
the leader when it comes to
environmental policy especially
with where we were during the trump
administration
well many other nations would say it's
only a start the u.s pledge is
significantly more ambitious than what
president obama set out six years ago
and it goes a long way
for other countries to uh restoring some
credibility after the last four years
under trump as you noted
uh the u.s pledge uh it's important to
notice it's also in keeping with what
many large environmental groups had
argued was both achievable and ambitious
for the us
but uh and this is important it's less
ambitious than
promises made by the uk and the european
union it's also unlikely to be
sufficient to keep average global
temperature
rise to below 1.5 degrees celsius which
is a key tipping point
so it's it's it's getting there but but
not even close to enough um
jen i want to talk a little bit about
what congressman garamendi told me
earlier in the show i spoke to him
democrat of northern california an area
of the country that has been hard hit by
climate change
he told us that there's not one one
republican who sees eye to eye when it
comes to climate policy
how does anything get done if that's the
case well so that is one of the big
challenges facing the president
uh you know and he's working to to win
over republicans right now on his
infrastructure package which is
you know loaded with items designed to
buttress
the us climate pledge uh you know the
the challenge that he's facing is
is big and he's trying to solve it by
building broad american support for his
climate agenda by illustrating that
you know this is about creating jobs and
revving up a clean energy economy if he
can get
you know broader buy-in from americans
you know that may be key to winning some
republican support
uh you know there's also growing
business support and interest from some
republican lawmakers for setting a
carbon tax
for doing some kind of price around
carbon dioxide that might be
something he can get through congress um
that has more support than a clean
energy standard something that mandates
clean electricity
yeah talk about more more about those
incentives and and what biden could
actually do because
well the government can only do so much
right so much of this has to come from
from businesses because these are the
the companies that are making a lot of
the decisions
that impact our climate and we'll only
have about uh a minute left jen
sure well you know we saw under
president trump how tenuous u.s pledges
of regulatory action on climate can be
and so what biden is trying to do here
is anchor as much of this as possible in
you know new laws and in as you noted
corporate action
in action by states and local
governments that's key to avoiding
the kind of fate we saw uh with u.s
policies under trump because
of course federal regulations can be
changed by a new occupant of the white
house
uh so so what we heard from the
president today was a real lean
on the actions of state and local
governments you know a big theme of the
president's address today was that the
u.s
climate commitment can be counted on
because it goes beyond the federal
government and it goes
into state houses and corporate
boardrooms alike
bloomberg climate policy reporter
jennifer delohe jennifer it's always
great to have you on the show thanks so
much for taking the time and for joining
us on this special edition
of quick take on earth day well coming
up
we're going to hear from the president
and ceo of earthday.org
we're going to look at the
organization's initiatives and its
expectations for president biden we're
back in two minutes this
is take a break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics
of global warming we can and we will
deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
take a break on earth day
i'm tim steinerbeck in new york well
parallel to biden's global climate
summit earthday.org is hosting its
second earth day live digital event
it includes workshops panel discussions
and special performances that focus on
the theme
restore our earth quick take anchor
jennifer zabasaja caught up earlier with
earthday.org ceo and president kathleen
rogers
on this year's initiatives check it out
let's bring in kathleen rogers she's the
president and ceo of earthday.org and
she's overseeing
many of the global actions that are
planned for today so kathleen thank you
so much for joining us on this really
busy day for you
so you call this you call this earth day
the most
important one yet why well a number of
reasons uh as you can imagine despite
the
sort of carbon respite we had during the
pandemic uh emissions are expected to
rise dramatically
this year and next the u.s has been out
of the climate business
and not just out of the climate business
but we had rolled back
we weren't just missing an action we
rolled back many of the protections that
we've seen
in the previous administration so now
we're back
and we'll see if the world takes it
seriously and how much
president biden is willing to commit
although i've heard it's
going to be a pretty stunning set of
recommendations and commitments
um and i so it's a combination of thing
and i also see
probably as important a huge amount of
activism and politicians and
corporations will never do
what they promised to do unless citizens
hold their feet to the fire and earth
days become sort of a watershed moment
we have even with covid we probably have
over a billion people doing something
so it's uh i think a year in the
beginning the re
uh launching of a decade of of climate
action
yeah and i want to talk about um you
know you mentioned the president of
course
uh he is meeting with world leaders over
the next uh day and he really has to
do a complete 180 right from what we've
seen over the past
few years how does he restore that
credibility in the u.s though what does
he need to say and what do you want to
hear him say
well i think there are a couple of
things one of the ways he's already
created a lot of interesting credibility
is because
a he ran on the k his campaign ran on
this but then he put his money where his
mouth was and
issued a number of executive orders but
most importantly he's hired some pretty
remarkable people john kerry in
particular who has
um amazing experience as a an elected
official
uh an important member of the
administration past administrations
and he is a diplomat has a lot of
credibility so i think the first step
is to reestablish the united states and
our willingness
to stay not just involved but to be the
leader on
climate reduction so we have hope based
on what we've heard that those
reductions will be significant
but it goes way beyond that it it also
includes
including trade which has always
remained outside the purview of the
climate conversation it includes
all facets of the federal government so
we're already seeing that move across
all agencies
and it includes a number of other really
important issues
that i think will kind of startle the
world i'm hoping they will
just to convince them that we're not
just back but we're back to stay
what are some of those well again um
the understanding is that he'll call for
50 reductions in emissions
by 2030 which is much more aggressive
than what we
committed to in the paris agreement and
again that's through all agencies
through all governments and it's a
national emissions
uh ceiling now how we define that and
how we approach it will it be easy no of
course not
but i do think it's a very aggressive
move um
he's also called on corporations and
other members of um
the public to stay really engaged and he
means business i think he's also
interested in having
uh citizens ordinary citizens hold his
feet and
and the feet of corporations to the fire
he's been very interested in public
participation
which of course is brand new i haven't
seen that in many many years not through
many
previous administrations so he's calling
on the public
um to do what i think we do best around
earth day which is to hold
governments and corporations accountable
and so you think
these steps that he is announcing they
go far enough or are there
are there more actions that you want to
see from this administration
well you know i'm an internal optimist
uh and so
we always like to see more aggressive
actions but i was actually surprised at
how aggressive
uh the reports are of what he's going to
commit to but he's added some really
important commitments the trade world
which i used to be a part of um
has very been out you know much outside
of
the conversation but he's including
trade agreements he's talking about
finance he's talking about supporting
emerging
emerging economies he's talking about
technology
and he's talking about um really
integrating and
uh climbing into every part of the
government he's putting as
huge amounts trillions of dollars in
infrastructure
um redevelopment but bill back better
he's dead serious about that we're
already seeing how that's playing out in
congress
and i do think his interest
in supporting environmental justice and
having activists play a role in how
um climate change has resolved those
issues i think is really important
he is looking for equity and um the
green economy is spread across
all uh levels of uh u.s society and so
many
of our vulnerable communities have been
left out of that in the tech industry
um and it's important to up to earth day
and apparently important to divine
administration to share that wealth
part of this um action in order to curb
emissions is going to
take everyone collectively being
involved right and i know
for your organization climate and
environmental literacy is is important
for you so
how do you push back against those
people who
are going against the facts and the and
the truths that are out there because
there are still a number of people
uh who are sort of working against what
it is that you're trying to do
i think in every revolution uh
industrial revolution agricultural
revolution
you have those people that for various
reasons either
their political for you know their foils
of politicians who want to maintain the
status quo
or people that just can't believe in the
future it is not unheard of for
large segments of the population to drag
behind the innovators
and i think that's what we're seeing now
is people like the status quo they're
comfortable with the status quo
they understand it they may be supported
by the oil industry certainly half of
congress
is and so what you need to do is just
convince them over time but i think
it'll be a short period of time
that there are green jobs there's money
that is available
that we can build a whole new class of
entrepreneurs that can be owned by many
many people not just a handful of
companies
and i think that will break down
resistance it's not like we haven't seen
this
in the american history over time they
reduced and resisted um the automobile
and um
they did that for a long time they
resisted uh safety in automobiles and
now they sell it so
we begin to see that um history repeats
itself but
as long as the economy keeps bumping
along and as long as people see the
opportunity to make money in the green
economy
and as long as we can provide funding to
those states where climate denial is
still a part of the curricula
i think they'll take the money i think
they'll grow and learn because they'll
see how good it is for their
students and for the universities that
they want to support so entrepreneurism
is very much alive in the united states
and
those states or individuals that resist
it will just
lose out on the opportunity and i think
they'll recognize that fairly quickly
it's part of the american fabric is
that spirit of entrepreneurship all
right well kathleen rogers president and
ceo of earthday.org
thank you so much for joining us on this
earth day here
thank you so much
and a big thank you to quick takes
jennifer zabasaja for that one
well coming up we're looking at how one
company aims to make jeans more
sustainable we're back in two minutes
this
is take a break
the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand
webinars only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
so
[Music]
we will make emission trading work not
only for energy generation and industry
but also for transport and for buildings
carbon must have its price because
nature cannot pay the price any longer
nature cannot pay the price any longer
that was european commission president
ursula von der lyons speaking earlier
today at president biden's virtual
global climate summit
welcome back to this very special earth
day edition of take a break i'm tim
stenovec in new york
well the modern age's most iconic piece
of clothing a pair of blue jeans
is also one of the most environmentally
harmful to make
billions of pairs are sold every year
from stylishly distressed to faded
vintage
styles that look worn out from hours in
the sun or repeated washing
are almost never so they've achieved
that effect right off the production
line from toxic chemicals mixed with
water
enrique sia the ceo and co-founder of
genologica has spent the past
26 years developing production methods
aimed at reducing
that pollution here's his story
fashion is about emotion making you feel
sexy
so we cannot develop a product
that protects the planet but compromise
the look
i started genealogia 25 years ago
i come from a textile family
denim jeans are the iconic garment
everybody has a genes in their wardrobe
to produce one gene
we contaminate 100 liters of water
20 percent of the water
that contaminates the river of the
planets are
at least coming from textile and
apparently industry
and i decided to create the company to
solve this problem
the first technology that we develop is
laser is using the energy of a laser
to distress the genes to reproduce the
effect of the past of the time
before this was known with a lot of
chemistry
the second technology also we are using
the air
to produce the stonewashed look and with
both technologies together we reduce 80
percent of the water consumption
but our ambition was zero waste so then
the third one is
nano bubbles in one centimeter you have
one million bubbles
and these bubbles like a cloth are
transporting chemistry
into the garments and with that
we reduce the amount of water from 100
liters
to only 10 liters so then we decide to
create h20
and that works like a kind of backpack
take the water
clean the water and put the water into
the system
again so the combinations of four
technologies
allowed us to produce genes with
zero water sheet of waste and without
contaminating the rivers of our planet
[Music]
today 35 percent of the genes that are
produced in the world
use our technologies levi strauss lee
tommy hilfier calming h m dolce gabanna
or dsl are using our technologies
during the 90s on the production ran
away
to countries where labor was
cheap because these countries at that
time didn't have regulations and
everything was possible you
you were able to produce destroying the
planet
and i'm sure that in the next five years
10 15 of the production is going to come
back to europe
it's going to come back to the u.s it's
going to come back to japan
it's going to come back near the
consumer
[Music]
in 2018 we create the first
plant in the history of textiles
in the desert of nevada in a place where
water was not available
that don't use water and cannot
contaminate water
it was unbelievable the achievement of
all our dreams
the main thing to make sure that
designers
are happy with the results and i will
say that it's not only happening
we are creating and providing tools to
the designers to make their dreams
a reality but in a way
that they do not contaminate our planet
[Music]
a big thank you to mark hall and
julianne wilkinson for that one
well coming up a 16 year old
environmentalist in uganda
plans to plant one million new trees in
the country's forest
we're back in two minutes with a little
bit of good news this
is take a break
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
concrete action is needed
we need such action
at a high speed on a large scale
and with a global scope
we in india are doing our part
that was india's prime minister narendra
modi speaking earlier today at president
biden's virtual
global climate summit welcome back to
this special earth day edition of take a
break
i'm tim stenovec now it's time for a
little bit of quick take good news on
this earth day
in the forest of uganda bare patches of
land like this are a common sight
forest cover here has depleted from 24
to just eight percent since the 1990s
it's a problem
all over the world according to global
forest watch
but one young activist is fighting back
sixteen-year-old
leah namagurwa has made it her mission
to replant the forests of her nation
she's planning on putting more than one
million trees back in the ground within
a decade
her birthday each year is the motivator
and leah's initiative is proving an
inspiration
far beyond the borders of uganda she
uses her social media power to encourage
other youngsters to regularly plant
trees as they celebrate their birthdays
her target of 1 million trees is still a
long way off but with
every new planting more and more people
join in that's going to do it for quick
take this hour on earth day you can
always check out the latest stories at
bloomberg.com also
check out bloomberg green our section
dedicated to bloomberg coverage of the
climate
you can also follow us at
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
we're now in this situation where
climate change
is an existential risk to our future
economy
and our way of life while the us
certainly has an uphill climb
i think it's it has a lot of support
from across the country
and is really in an important way
centering climate action
at the core of economic recovery we will
raise our radar to search
of any technology which can contribute
to
force to achieve this goal so we will be
more
investing to dc and the ventures
having 70 trillion of private capital
coming behind that zero which is what's
being announced today
is the type of momentum the world needs
good afternoon and welcome to bloomberg
quick take where we bring you today's
top news and break down how it
intersects with the world of business
today's earth day and over the next hour
we're going to hear from leaders across
industries and regions on their efforts
to fight climate change and mobilize
others to do the same good afternoon
everyone it's thursday april 22nd i'm
tim stenoveck in new york
let's get going
[Music]
good afternoon everyone well president
biden has brought together world leaders
for a virtual summit on climate change
the president made a new commitment to
cut u.s fossil fuel emissions up to 52
percent
by 2030. that marks a return to global
climate efforts after four years of
withdrawal
under president trump in order to reach
that goal transportation secretary pete
budejedge says congress needs to pass
the american jobs plan
that president biden has proposed
this is a whole of government and whole
of society efforts so
no one piece of legislation even an
enormously important one like the jobs
plan
is going to be the whole story
especially because there are things like
the
technologies that that haven't yet fully
developed like we were talking about
with
aviation fuel a lot of change coming to
how people get around that will by
2030 look quite different
with me now is congressman john
garamendi a democrat representing
california's third district it's in
northern california congressman thanks
so much for taking the time
what does congress agree on when it
comes to the environment when it comes
to climate change do democrats and
republicans see eye to eye
on anything
the answer is no and that's the tragedy
here
and that's the problem for this entire
planet is that
we are not able to develop a consensus
within the congress to really do the
things that are necessary
to address climate change and it is a
structural change as
secretary budeck alluded to it's a
structural change
away from fossil fuels it can be done
there is no doubt that it can be done
but it's going to take
government to lead and that means we
have to change the incentives
so that people and industry are willing
and
financially able to
green technologies and we have to
eliminate the incentives that exist
today for the fossil fuel industry
particularly the petroleum industry
which has an
enormous for 120 years of
government incentives to pump more oil
and gas out of the ground
okay so let's start with the incentives
that you that you want to see what do
you think the federal government needs
to do
in order to encourage companies to make
these changes
that would slow down a climate change
well first of all we need a carbon tax
and it can be a
fully refundable carbon tax or any other
thing but you've got to put a pricing
mechanism into this
so that the uh system that is the
economic system will respond to the
price
signal that carbon fuels are
expensive secondly we need to provide
the
financial incentives and these are
subsidies of various kinds
for battery storage and i'm not just
talking about chemical batteries but
other kinds of batteries and there are
many different ways we can store energy
and secondly fully develop and put in
place the
green renewable technologies
uh congressman you're from northern cal
well you live in northern california
you've been there for
a very long time and i'm wondering how
you've seen
climate change play out in your district
and what changes
you've seen and i'm wondering
specifically if you could get some of
your republican colleagues to go back to
your district with you
what you would show them to show them
that this is
uh something dire that needs to be
addressed
i would show them a fire season it is no
longer six or seven months of the year
but
but 12 months of the year i'll show them
communities that are gone because
they've been totally destroyed
by wildfires i will show them a national
forest of which more than half of the
forest
is gone i would show them a continuing
drought
back in 1977 when i started my ranching
operation that was a one-year
drought and it was devastating we now
have droughts occurring
once every two three four years uh
interrupted by a wet season that is a
devastating wet season
literally a uh a tsunami of water coming
out of the sky
and so we're getting this extreme
weather
we're getting hot come to california in
the summertime northern california which
used to have a few
days over 100 degrees now we have months
over 100 degrees uh it is a very serious
problem and by the way
i'll show you tropical diseases that
never existed
in california that are there now i'm in
new york now but i grew up in california
and i absolutely know what you're
talking about i've seen it firsthand my
parents are still there
uh and yeah it's it's happening but i
wonder why this is a a
partisan issue why do you think this is
something that goes down party lines
because there are plenty of republicans
who live in areas of the country that
have been significantly affected and
severely affected by climate change
i i don't know i i guess we all
in one way or another we adopt a
position and we're unwilling to change
it
even in the face of uh drought and
calamitous fires and the like we're
unwilling to change uh it becomes a
mantra
a mantra that we've come to use to
advance our own political careers
a mantra that we used uh in the face of
devastating facts unwilling to change
uh you know and i suppose the
republicans will say the same about us
that
all we want to do is to shut down the
petroleum industry
we're not interested in jobs i heard it
earlier this morning
from one of our colleagues about the uh
the pipelines that were that
biden shut down uh and so
they talk about jobs but on the job side
it
is a fact that the green technologies
actually are going to be the jobs of the
future uh not the petroleum industry not
the coal industry i was talking to one
of my colleagues from
west virginia and he said we're going to
be down to just
two congressional districts he said just
years ago we had six
and i said population is leaving he said
yes
population is leaving for a variety of
reasons there is a transition occurring
here in america and around the world
away from fossil fuels
the faster we do that the faster we move
to the green tech
technologies to the renewables to the
way in which we can store energy the
grid systems
all of those things the faster we will
recover and
if we do this with american technology
and
make it in america which is an
absolutely a critical part of this
transition
not relying upon china for our wind
turbines but rather
making it in america we will create
those jobs we'll create the
opportunities
and we will be able to attack the
climate christ
congressman i want to end talking about
that renewable energy today
kathy wood of arc invest along with
tesla's elon musk
uh and jack dorsey of twitter and square
um
they are supporting a claim that bitcoin
can actually help the planet by
encouraging
more solar projects and thereby reducing
their cost
we should note that renewable energy
costs are going down
regardless of bitcoin but i'm wondering
if you have any thoughts on that
i i think we need to separate these
issues
we need not to bring into the debate
other complexities uh the it is complex
enough
to put in place the financial incentives
to go green that we must do if we do
that
these other pieces that are on the
outside of it
uh will come into place how do you
finance it how do you
do these i don't know new technologies
or new
financial technologies but we do know
that we must do it it's a fact
uh we're right now we've got an armed
services hearing going on
we know that our major military bases
cannot survive in the climate of
tomorrow
the sea level rises is an extraordinary
problem for the world's biggest
uh naval base and that's norfolk
in virginia they're going to have to
have waiters to get
to the ships right and you go beyond
that so the resiliency of the military
and right now one of the things that i'm
doing
is to force the military to reduce this
energy consumption
by going green by going with hybrid
vehicles
all of these things are possible we need
to force
our systems we cannot just stand by and
think it's going to evolve
it has to be forced upon the american
economy and when we do it
the military will be better off because
the most
dangerous thing for the military is the
transportation of fuel
congressman we're going to have to leave
it there thank you so much for taking
the time
democratic representative john garamendi
of california congressman thanks so much
we appreciate you joining us thank you
one quick take on earth day today
well in the fight against climate change
young people are taking the lead
pushing for change advocating for
climate literacy and demanding more from
world leaders
one of the organizations leading the
fight is the sunrise movement it's a
youth movement to stop climate change
and create millions of jobs in the
process
they've participated in sit-ins and
climate strikes across the country
and in 2020 they contacted over 6.5
million voters in the primaries and in
the general election helping create the
largest youth turnout
in history sunrise movement national
spokesperson lily gardner joins me now
from lexington
lexington kentucky lily thanks so much
for being here it is so great to have
you on the show
i want to get your reaction to what
we're hearing from world leaders so far
today
is what you're hearing enough
absolutely so i think president biden in
particular's commitment
to cutting emissions by 2030
has really been lauded as a start
but we know that it's not enough right
and i think that
if he wants to earn the title of
international climate leader
then we need to think about the science
that is so
clearly telling us that we have to we
have we have to
cut global emissions um in half by 2030
and we know that the us is the country
with the most historical responsibility
and the greatest economic capacity to do
that
and so we need to be bold with our
vision and
i think a real part of that is going
bolder than just saying
we're going to cut in half by 2030 and
thinking
thinking about what more we can achieve
i'm wondering the best way to do this
though does it does it come
from electing electing members of
of congress and other elected officials
who are in line with your cause as the
sunrise movement
tried to do in the latest election or
does more need to be done
i think that's certainly one component
right electing
officials who are in line with the
vision for a green new deal
is certainly going to support massive
government
investment that we know is necessary and
we know that president biden can be a
real leader in this moment
and stick to the campaign promises we
fought for and he has made
including things like the civilian
climate corps to make these realities a
possible
or possibility even sooner than the next
election cycle
what is the best way to communicate
these issues because i think that
you know a lot of people can can think
about
it's it's hard because i think for a lot
of people climate change
is one of those things that they can
ignore and
and not actually think affects their
day-to-day life and
and that certainly changes when we have
natural disasters and to what extent
they are
connected to a changing climate um
scientists can debate about that and
specific disasters there but
what is the best way to communicate this
to to young people right now to make
them care about something
uh that they have trouble visualizing
perhaps
sure so i think in many ways young
people are a generation
that has had to grapple with the impacts
of the climate crisis for our entire
lives
but when i think more broadly about how
we talk about the climate crisis
i think about my home in appalachia
which has been so
devastated by the impacts of the coal
and fossil fuel industries
and yet the i think the dominant
narrative
is one that jobs are in
really in tension with the possibility
of stopping climate change and that
we are fundamentally not aligned on our
values when i think that is
really not the case and so often i start
these conversations
whether it be with young people people
who might not be
politically aligned with me or just an
ordinary person in my community
from the base of a value like everyone
having access to a good dignified job
that doesn't force them
to choose between their health and
putting food on the table
lily you mentioned coal and fossil fuels
so i want to get your reaction to what
greta tunberg said
earlier today testifying at a u.s
congressional hearing on fossil fuel
subsidies she said quote
we have to end fossil fuel subsidy stop
new exploration and extraction
completely divest from fossil fuels and
keep the carbon
in the ground what are your thoughts on
that do you agree with her
absolutely i think that's spot on and i
think that
in that process we really hold the
workers of
fossil fuel industries through con yeah
through ideas like
adjust transition supporting
whole communities and transitioning away
from these economies that were based on
extractive industries
into ones that support care work and
perhaps renewable energy jobs
and these myriad things through programs
like the civilian climate corps
as you saw i just spoke with congressman
garamendi of northern california a
district that has been
hard hit by climate change drought fires
you name it
he said though that republicans and
democrats don't come
anywhere close to agreeing when it comes
what to do
to what to do about the climate are you
hopeful though
i think i could not do this work if i
wasn't hopeful
in the power of our communities that
being said
republicans have chosen time and again
that they are going to be the party of
violence and the party that is
going to condemn both our futures and
our presence and the real experiences of
environmental injustice
that are happening across the united
states as we speak
and so i think while i'm hopeful when i
have conversations with fellow
organizers
i also know that it's going to take a
lot
including right the abolition of the jim
crow filibuster
and real leadership from president biden
in a bold and divisive way for us to
overcome
this entrenched party divide and and
pass legislation that's going to make a
real
impact on people's lives lily gardner we
are going to have to leave it there
that's lily gardner sunrise movement
national spokesperson lily thanks so
much for
taking the time really appreciate you
joining us on earth day thank you for
having me
now we don't want to bury the lead on
the rest of the day's top news so here
are some climate stories we do not want
you to miss
on earth day bloomberg has learned that
the biden administration will restore
california's power to limit auto
emissions
it's a shift that will lead to tougher
requirements across much of the us
two trump era policies limited
california's ability to set ambitious
vehicle standards and kathy woods arc
investment has
new research that says bitcoin mining
isn't as environmentally damaging as
some
claim it is often criticized as a highly
energy intensive activity but arc says
bitcoin mining could encourage
investment in solar energy systems
and energy providers could play the
arbitrage between electricity prices
and bitcoin prices we should note that
the trends in the clean energy industry
are already happening and the prices
are for renewables are going down and
entries for elon musk's carbon removal
competition opened today he announced
the competition a few months back
and the huge 100 million dollars of
prize money that's up for grabs
even though the competition opens up
today winners won't get their prize
money for four years
three winners will be named for three
separate prizes 50 million
20 million dollars in 10 million dollars
that's happening
on earth day 2025 so get to work about
the competition musk said quote carbon
negativity
not neutrality this is not a theoretical
competition
whatever it takes time is of the essence
you can always learn more about these
stories and stay up to date on today's
news at bloomberg.com
well coming up next the fashion industry
has grown into one of the top
contributors to global carbon emissions
so what's being done to slow down fast
fashion
we're talking to an expert in the
industry on ways that the fashion
industry can shift
we're back in two minutes this is take a
break
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
canada is now on track to blow past
our old target of 30 reduction below
2005 levels last december
we strengthened our climate plan to
reduce more emissions
including with a world-leading price on
pollution
well that of course was canadian prime
minister justin trudeau speaking earlier
today
at u.s president joe biden's climate
summit on his country's push to lower
emissions welcome back to this very
special earth day edition of take a
break i'm tim steinebeck in new york
it's time now for quick take by the
numbers it's where we let the data tell
the story
this afternoon's number is 10 in 2019
the fashion industry was responsible for
10
of annual global carbon emissions more
than all international flights and
maritime shipping
combined at this pace the fashion
industry's greenhouse gas emissions
will surge more than 50 percent by 2030
that's according to the united nations
environment program so get this
to make one pair of jeans it takes about
7 500
liters of water that's equivalent to the
amount of water that the average person
drinks
over a period of seven years
mind-boggling
well our next guest has seen firsthand
how the fashion industry affects the
environment
and the people involved she's toured the
world as a celebrity stylist working
with artists like drake nicki minaj and
lionel richie
and now she has her very own shop in los
angeles that works to bring socially and
environmentally conscious fashion
to the masses founder and creative
director of gallery la dashelle
mckillion joins us now to shell thank
you so much for
taking the time i want to talk about
what goes into
making a garment you just heard me talk
about the the staggering amount of water
that it takes to make a pair of jeans
but i still think there's this
disconnect between what we wear and the
impact that it has on the environment
that's so much different than
what we think about when we drive in a
car or or you know
sieve smog in la or or get on an
airplane why is that
yes i agree and i mean i found out
that through just normal consumerism
we don't know how garments are made
fashion has a huge supply chain
from you know just think of the cotton
that's grown
in our soil to that cotton going to
a factory that's creating fabric to that
fabric then
creating a garment to that garment that
you're wearing
and a lot of the impact actually that
fashion has
and the items that we're buying happens
after we actually buy the garment so
it's how we take care of the garment
what are we doing after we dispose of it
all of these lead to a big environmental
impact that just kind of adds up
so what should we be doing what should
we be doing as consumers
when it comes to understanding what
we're buying
what we're wearing and how we're taking
care of it through its life cycle
yes you know for me i think it's about
slowing down
i really think it comes to self
especially in america we're bombarded
with
so much marketing of buying products
that we
actually don't need so
once you slow down and you can actually
ask ask yourself do i need this do i
need to like just
impulse buy this item right now
and so beyond that impulse buy you can
start to look at a brand's website that
you might be
going on and being more intentional you
can see see
what the item what the material is look
for eco-friendly fabrics
look for recycled fabrics and processes
look to see if these brands have ethical
factories
look to see you know are they using zero
waste in their
production um there's so many questions
that we can begin to
ask as consumers and i think that once
you slow down
from that you know i gotta buy buy buy
you know just being at this moment you
can actually explore different
options you know there's rentals where
you know we have like weddings and you
just go ahead and
you know buy that one thing that you're
just gonna wear
once and then you donate it but you
could rip that item
instead of buying and keep extending
fashion's life cycle
they're swapped you can go to swaps
inside
and swap with friends now there's thread
up where you can
get items that would normally be
discarded at just very
low prices so you know i think again it
comes to the slowing down and there's a
lot of options
dash how do you do this so affordably
you mentioned some some great options
there especially for secondhand clothes
but if i think about this from the
perspective of buying a new garment
there are companies that you can buy
from that have transparency right
patagonia is one that comes to mind but
those clothes are
are really expensive and one thing that
we have seen with the rise of
globalization
has meant lower prices for consumers
uh and that's really what fast fashion
has been and it hasn't been great for
the environment but the incentives to me
don't seem like they're right because
that stuff is so cheap so how do you
bring the prices down
for environmentally friendly garments
yes
i mean again i don't want to say that
all companies that are
saying they're environmentally friendly
are ethical but it comes down to
the garment workers are they being paid
fair wages
for
beyond that there's so much
more that goes into the actual making of
a garment
um that we can as consumers can ask
questions about so tell me how you're
doing this
uh as a celebrity stylist and and how
you're doing this
at gallery la yes so when i was a
celebrity stylist that's how i
first realized fashion's impact on our
planet i was traveling places
and just seeing like so much pollution
that was clothing
it was shoes the factories how our
things were made
and as a celebrity stylist you put
something on a celebrity and people just
buy it because it's on a celebrity and
then
you know discard of it so i realized my
own impact and really that's where
gallery la was born is because i was
looking for
fashion brands that were producing their
clothing responsibly
and within a lot of research i
came to see that okay if sustainable
fashion is so hard to understand
we're not gonna buy it it has to be cool
it has to be easy to understand so we
develop the sustainable value badge
system
that really makes it easy for people to
shop their values
so everything that we carry at gallery
la is ethically made meaning our brands
work with their factories they know that
workers are getting paid fair wages they
know they
have safe working conditions so that's
like the main criteria
and then beyond that brands use
eco-friendly
materials they use recycled materials
and up cycle processes vegan materials
eliminating all animal and animal
byproducts
they work with artisans all around the
world
to you know produce their items so
instead
of us getting rid of these traditions we
can actually embrace
traditions like hand weaving and natural
dyeing processes
to keep the global economy afloat right
and yes that's how we do it and i'm
curating each and every piece
so everything that we carry i'm hand
selecting
i want it to be in you know your closet
for years to come
it's based on quality it's based on
design it's based on
you know timelessness dashell i i we
don't have much time left but i want to
talk about something that
that you have touched on uh the
challenges of starting a sustainably
focused company as a black woman um one
of your latest initiatives
targets this specifically tell us what
gallery la's goodie bag initiative is
yeah so last june amid all the
unrest that was happening you know i
just
felt that as a black woman there was so
much
more that even i could do in this space
because to be honest starting a
sustainable fashion business and
the vision that i had and like taking to
venture capitalists and just sharing
this idea
i got so much pushback and
you know i didn't realize oh maybe it's
because of a black woman i'm just like
okay they're not ready for it so i just
kind of chugged along
but so often you know as a black
business owner
we are really just you know trying to
make it happen and with the pandemic
there were so many black businesses
struggling and so in sustainable fashion
and wellness and clean beauty there's so
many black brands
that just are not getting the attention
they are not
you know being pushed to the front of
you know big retailers that you would
like to see so at gallery la
i developed the goody bag to just make
it easy for you to discover
sustainable brands in the clothing
wellness and clean beauty industries
and support these businesses during this
time because they have amazing products
and it's about time that we you know
like
spread it yeah it is about time
gallery la founder and creative director
deshelle mckinley michelle thank you so
much for taking the time and for joining
us
on earth day today well coming up next
is the u.s poised to become the global
leader
of climate policy we'll be back in two
minutes to discuss where biden's agenda
lies
when it comes to other countries this is
take a break
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change in
the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to this very special earth
day edition of take a break i'm tim
stenovec in new york
well president biden convening 40 world
leaders in a virtual summit intended to
demonstrate renewed american resolve to
fight climate change
bloomberg's climate policy reporter
jennifer deloie has been following it
all and joins me now from washington dc
to discuss
hey jennifer it's always great to have
you on the show what are your sources
saying about biden's climate pledge is
it ambitious enough to make the u.s the
leader
when it comes to environmental policy
especially with where we were during the
trump administration
well many other nations would say it's
only a start the u.s pledge
is significantly more ambitious than
what president obama set out six years
ago and it goes a long way
for other countries to uh restoring some
credibility after the last four years
under trump as you noted
uh the u.s pledge uh it's important to
notice it's also in keeping with what
many large environmental groups had
argued was both achievable and ambitious
for the us
but uh and this is important it's less
ambitious than
promises made by the uk and the european
union it's also unlikely to be
sufficient to keep
average global temperature rise to below
1.5 degrees celsius which is a key
tipping point
so it's it's it's getting there but but
not even close to enough
um jen i want to talk a little bit about
what congressman garamendi
told me earlier in the show i spoke to
him democrat of northern california an
area of the country that has been hard
hit by climate change
he told us that there's not one one
republican who sees eye to eye when it
comes to climate policy
how does anything get done if that's the
case well so that is one of the big
challenges facing the president
uh you know and he's working to to win
over republicans right now on his
infrastructure package which is
you know loaded with items designed to
buttress the u.s
climate pledge uh you know the the
challenge that he's facing is
is big and he's trying to solve it by
building broad american support for his
climate agenda by illustrating that
you know this is about creating jobs and
revving up a clean energy economy if he
can get
you know broader buy-in from americans
you know that may be key to winning some
republican support
uh you know there's also growing
business support and interest from
some republican lawmakers for setting a
carbon tax
for doing some kind of price around
carbon dioxide
that might be something he can get
through congress that has more support
than a clean energy standard something
that mandates
clean electricity yeah talk about more
about those incentives and
and what biden could actually do because
well the government can only do so much
right so much of this has to come from
from businesses because these are the
the companies that are making a lot of
the decisions that impact our climate
and we'll
only have about a minute left jen sure
well you know we saw under president
trump how tenuous
u.s pledges of regulatory action on
climate can be and so what biden
is trying to do here is anchor as much
of this as possible
in you know new laws and in as you noted
corporate action
in action by states and local
governments that's key to avoiding
the kind of fate we saw uh with u.s
policies under trump because
of course federal regulations can be
changed by a new occupant of the white
house
uh so so what we heard from the
president today was a real lien
on the actions of state and local
governments you know a big theme of the
president's address today was that the
u.s climate commitment can be counted on
because it goes beyond the federal
government and it goes into state houses
and corporate boardrooms alike bloomberg
climate policy reporter jennifer delohe
jennifer it's always great to have you
on the show thanks so much for taking
the time and for joining us on this
special edition
of quick take on earth day well coming
up
we're going to hear from the president
and ceo of earthday.org
we're going to look at the
organization's initiatives and its
expectations for president biden
we're back in two minutes this is take a
break
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
take a break on earth day
i'm tim steineveck in new york well
parallel to biden's global climate
summit earthday.org is hosting its
second earth day live digital event
it includes workshops panel discussions
and special performances that focus on
the theme
restore our earth quick take anchor
jennifer zavasaja caught up earlier with
earthday.org ceo and president kathleen
rogers
on this year's initiatives check it out
let's bring in kathleen rogers she's the
president and ceo of earthday.org and
she's overseeing many of the global
actions that are planned for today so
kathleen thank you so much for joining
us on this really busy day for you
so you call this you call this earth day
the most
important one yet why well a number of
reasons uh as you can imagine despite
the
sort of carbon respite we had during the
pandemic uh emissions are expected to
rise dramatically
this year and next the u.s has been out
of the climate business
and not just out of the climate business
but we had rolled back
we weren't just missing an action we
rolled back many of the protections that
we've seen
in the previous administration so now
we're back
and we'll see if the world takes it
seriously and how much
president biden is willing to commit
although i've heard it's
going to be a pretty stunning set of
recommendations and commitments
uh and i so it's a combination of thing
and i also see
probably as important a huge amount of
activism and politicians and
corporations will never do
what they promised to do unless citizens
hold their feet to the fire and earth
day's become sort of a watershed moment
uh we have even with covid we probably
have over a billion people doing
something
so it's uh i think a year in the
beginning the re
uh launching of a decade of of of
climate action
yeah and i want to talk about um you
know you mentioned the president of
course
uh he is meeting with world leaders over
the next uh day and he really has to
do a complete 180 right from what we've
seen over the past
few years how does he restore that
credibility in the u.s though what does
he need to say and what do you want to
hear him say
well i think there are a couple of
things one of the ways he's already
created a lot of interesting credibility
is because
a he ran on the his campaign ran on this
but then he put his money where his
mouth was and issued a number of
executive orders
but most importantly he's hired some
pretty remarkable people
john kerry in particular who has
amazing experience as a an elected
official
an important member of the
administration past administrations
and he is a diplomat has a lot of
credibility so i think the first step
is to reestablish the united states and
our willingness
to stay not just involved but to be the
leader on
climate reduction so we have hope based
on what we've heard that those
reductions will be significant
but it goes way beyond that it also
includes
including um trade which has always
remained outside the purview of the
climate conversation it includes
all facets of the federal government so
we're already seeing that move across
all agencies
and it includes a number of other really
important issues
that i think will kind of startle the
world i'm hoping they will
just to convince them that we're not
just back but we're back to stay
what are some of those well again um
the understanding is that he'll call for
50 reductions in emissions
by 2030 which is much more aggressive
than what we
committed to in the paris agreement and
again that's through all
agencies through all governments and
it's a national emissions
uh ceiling now how we define that and
how we approach it will it be easy no of
course not
but i do think it's a very aggressive
move
he's also called on corporations and
other members of
the public to stay really engaged and he
means business i think he's also
interested in having
uh citizens ordinary citizens hold his
feet and and the feet of corporations to
the fire he's been
very interested in public participation
which of course is brand new i haven't
seen that
in many many years not through many
previous administrations so
he's calling on the public um to do what
i think we do best around earth day
which is to hold
governments and corporations accountable
and so you think
these steps that he is announcing they
go far enough or are there
are there more actions that you want to
see from this administration
well you know i'm an internal optimist
uh and so
we always like to see more aggressive
actions but i was actually surprised at
how aggressive
uh the reports are of what he's going to
commit to but he's added some really
important commitments the trade world
which i used to be a part of
um has very been out you know much
outside of
the conversation but he's including
trade agreements he's talking about
finance he's talking about supporting
emerging
emerging economies he's talking about
technology
and he's talking about um really
integrating and
uh climbing into every part of the
government he's putting as
huge amounts trillions of dollars in
infrastructure
um redevelopment but bill back better
he's dead serious about that we're
already seeing how that's playing out in
congress
and i do think his um interest
in supporting environmental justice and
having activists play a role in how
um climate change has resolved those
issues
i think is really important he is
looking for equity
and um the green economy is spread
across all
uh levels of uh us society and so many
of our vulnerable communities have been
left out of that in the tech industry
um and it's important to up to earth day
and apparently important to divide
administration to share that wealth
part of this um action in order to curb
emissions is going to take
everyone collectively being involved
right and i know for
your organization climate and
environmental literacy is is important
for you so
how do you push back against those
people who
are going against the facts and the and
the truths that are out there because
there are still a number of people
uh who are sort of working against what
it is that you're trying to do
i think in every revolution uh
industrial revolution
agricultural revolution you have those
people that
for various reasons either their
political for you know their foils of
politicians who want to maintain the
status quo or
people that just can't believe in the
future it is not unheard of for
large segments of the population to drag
behind the innovators
and i think that's what we're seeing now
is people like the status quo they're
comfortable with the status quo they
understand it they may be supported by
the oil industry
certainly half of congress is and so
what you need to do is just convince
them
over time but i think it'll be a short
period of time that there are green jobs
there's money that is available that we
can build a whole new class of
entrepreneurs that can be owned by many
many people not just a handful of
companies
and i think that will break down
resistance it's not like we haven't seen
this
in the american history over time they
reduced and resisted um the automobile
and um they did that for a long time
they resisted
uh safety in automobiles and now they
sell it so we begin to see that
um history repeats itself but as long as
the economy
keeps bumping along and as long as
people see the opportunity to make money
in the green economy
and as long as we can provide funding to
those states where climate denial is
still
a part of the curricula i think they'll
take the money i think they'll grow and
learn because they'll see how good it is
for their
students and for the universities that
they want to support so entrepreneurism
is very much alive in the united states
and
those states or individuals that resist
it will just lose out on the opportunity
and i think they'll recognize that
fairly quickly it's part of the american
fabric is
that spirit of entrepreneurship all
right well kathleen rogers president and
ceo of earthday.org
thank you so much for joining us on this
earth day here
thank you so much
and a big thank you to quick takes
jennifer zabasaja for that one
well coming up we're looking at how one
company aims to make jeans more
sustainable we're back in two minutes
this
is take a break
the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand
webinars only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
we will make emission trading work not
only for energy generation and industry
but also for transport and for buildings
carbon must have its price because
nature cannot pay the price any longer
nature cannot pay the price any longer
that was european commission president
ursula van der lions speaking earlier
today at president biden's virtual
global climate summit
welcome back to this very special earth
day edition of take a break i'm tim
stenovec
in new york well the modern age's most
iconic piece of clothing a pair of blue
jeans
is also one of the most environmentally
harmful to make
billions of pairs are sold every year
from stylishly distressed to faded
vintage
styles that look worn out from hours in
the sun or repeated washing
are almost never so they've achieved
that effect right off the production
line from toxic chemicals mixed with
water
enrique sia the ceo and co-founder of
genologica has spent the past
26 years developing production methods
aimed at reducing
that pollution here's his story
fashion is about emotion making you feel
sexy
so we cannot develop a product
that protects the planet but compromise
the look
i started genealogia 25 years ago
i come from a textile family
denim jeans are the iconic garment
everybody has a jeans in their wardrobe
to produce one gene
we contaminate 100 liters of water
20 percent of the water
that contaminates the river of the
planets are
fish coming from textile and apparently
industry
and i decided to create the company to
solve this problem
the first technology that we develop is
laser is using the energy
of a laser to distress the genes to
reproduce the effect of the past of the
time
before this was known with a lot of
chemistry
the second technology also we are using
the air to produce the
stonewashed look and with both
technologies together
we reduce 80 percent of the water
consumption but our ambition was
zero waste so then the third one is nano
bubbles
in one centimeter you have one million
bubbles
and these bubbles like a cloth are
transporting chemistry
into the garments and with that
we reduce the amount of water from
hundred liters
to only 10 liters so then we decide to
create h20
and that works like a kind of backpack
take the water
clean the water and put the water into
the system
again so the combinations of four
technologies
allowed us to produce genes with
zero water sheet of waste and without
contaminating the rivers of our planet
[Music]
today 35 of the genes that are produced
in the world
use our technologies levi strauss lee
tommy hilfier calming h m dolce gabbana
or dsl are using our technologies
during the 90s on the production ran
away
to countries where labor was
cheap because these countries at that
time didn't have regulations and
everything was possible
you you were able to produce destroying
the planet and i'm sure that in the next
five years
10 15 of the production is going to
come back to europe it's going to come
back to the u.s
it's going to come back to japan it's
going to come back near the consumer
[Music]
in 2018 we create the first
plant in the history of textiles
in the desert of nevada in a place where
water was not available
that don't use water and cannot
contaminate water
it was unbelievable the achievement of
all our dreams
the main thing to make sure that
designers
are happy with the results and i will
say that it's not only happening
we are creating and providing tools to
the designers to make their dreams
a reality but in a way
that they do not contaminate our planet
[Music]
a big thank you to mark hall and
julianne wilkinson for that one
well coming up a 16 year old
environmentalist in uganda
plans to plant one million new trees in
the country's forest
we're back in two minutes with a little
bit of good news this
is take a break
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
concrete action is needed
we need such action
at a high speed on a large scale
and with a global scope
we in india are doing our part
that was india's prime minister narendra
modi speaking earlier today at president
biden's virtual
global climate summit welcome back to
this special earth day edition of take a
break
i'm tim stenovec now it's time for a
little bit of quick take good news on
this earth day
in the forest of uganda bare patches of
land like this
are a common sight forest cover here has
depleted from 24
to just 8 since the 1990s it's a problem
all over the world according to global
forest watch
but one young activist is fighting back
sixteen-year-old
leah namaguerwa has made it her mission
to replant the forest of her nation
she's planning on putting more than one
million trees back in the ground within
a decade
her birthday each year is the motivator
and leah's initiative is proving an
inspiration
far beyond the borders of uganda she
uses her social media power to encourage
other youngsters to regularly plant
trees as they celebrate their birthdays
her target of one million trees is still
a long way off but with every new
planting
more and more people join in
well that's going to do it for quick
take this hour on earth day you can
always check out the latest stories at
bloomberg.com also check out bloomberg
green
our section dedicated to bloomberg
coverage of the climate
you can also follow us
[Music]
so
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what we are doing in our lab right now
is i think for the first time truly the
first steps towards building
cybernetic systems cyborgs
you know we've been reading about this
in our science fiction for years
and it's finally starting to get there
my entire life i never thought that i
would be where i am now
having had an amputation i have an
opportunity to
engineer my own body and i had always
dreamed about that
the implications of making a seamless
connection between
the body and the robot means that we end
disability
[Music]
my name is everett lawson i'm a research
assistant at mit
in the media lab
i don't know that i would necessarily
call myself an inventor
but i like to make things and i like to
make things that
allow me to see and feel and experience
things
that i would have not otherwise been
able to
[Music]
i was born with a congenital clubbed
foot
and what it really came down to is that
the bones
were weaker so even just stepping off of
a curb i could break my foot
i remember once i was running from a
bear
on a dirt road and i stepped on a rock
and i broke my foot
[Music]
a few years ago my wife and i found out
that we were going to have our son
august and i had reconstructive surgery
to allow me to run around and chase my
son
and pick him up after he was born oh
really
[Music]
and after having that surgery uh
i didn't heal my leg was just absolutely
deteriorating
and the surgeon said well we think that
an amputation is going to be the best
outcome for you and i was sitting in my
office
dumb struck and a great mentor
of mine happened to come to my office
and saw me sitting there
and he literally grabbed me by the arm
and he said that's it and
he took me and he marched me downstairs
across the lab down into hewhere's lab
my name is hugh her i'm a professor at
mit
and i direct a research group called the
biomechatronics group
we develop wearable robots robots that
attach to the body
mechanically and neurally
we met with uh everett that day and uh
determined that everett would benefit
from receiving the
ewing amputation this experimental
surgery
which is a truly unique approach to
performing an amputation
in a traditional amputation not only are
they cutting through the bone but
they're also
cutting through all the muscles and
tendons as well
in the ewing procedure they preserve as
much of that musculature as they can
and the relationship of those muscles
via their tendons
i still have the musculature embedded
into my limb
which means that i can have a direct
neuromuscular interface with bionic
limbs
and that's how i started this
relationship with the biomechatronics
[Music]
lab
my name is matt carney i'm a phd
candidate here in the biomechatronics
group and i have been building
bionic knees and ankles trying to push
the limits of what's actually possible
to get as close as possible or even
better than
biological performance what's really
interesting about everett is that
because he's had this amputation it
allows him to
have this neural pathway that a
traditional amputation doesn't
necessarily have
so that he can have direct control of
the robot
[Music]
how it works is that there are sensors
that
read the signals coming out of the
muscles in my leg
and it translates them into mechanical
motion within the bionic limb
so when i fire a muscle that would say
point your foot down
it directly translates to a motion in
the
robotic ankle i think you should have
control
[Music]
range of motion for the dorsiflexion
feels really good
it does yeah i remember the first time
that i you know saw
matt's robotic ankle and he turned on
the controls
i wasn't seeing the mechanics of this
robot attached to my body
i was seeing my body being continued all
the way down to a foot
that had a one-to-one relationship
between the thought of motion
and actual motion it was
truly profound
all right so you can put it on we'll try
it out we'll turn it up a little bit
great
i need a little bit more resistance on
heel strike
well yes more dampening for heel strike
how does it feel i just made it
that's way better quite a bit stiffer
yeah
working with matt and the team in the
position of being
a subject is a really interesting
situation for me
but i also am an engineer and an
inventor and
you know i also work on developing my
own systems
and rather than trying to translate my
thoughts
into motion i'm looking at how do i get
sensory feedback
back in so i received this experimental
surgery
which preserved a lot of the musculature
of my leg
as well as portions of the nervous
system and
i began to realize that there were
specific spots on my leg
that have an approximate sensation of
the big toe the little toe the heel the
middle of my foot
and it was at that point that i started
prototyping building things
in order to start exploring these
sensations
within the last 48 hours i've been able
to
build an array of sensors that go to the
bottom of my prosthetic
they send a signal back onto my residual
limb a little bit of electricity across
the surface of the skin
to get the sensation of touch
so i can reach down and i can touch
this one and i have the sensation of my
little toe
wow august do you want to come help papa
do you want to help me do science
you want to tickle the bottom of papa's
robot foot
hold on the bottom all the way on the
bottom
i'll push that one whoa i feel that
can you push other buttons you're
touching my pinky toe
and my big toe and it actually really
tickles
i hadn't thought some of this all the
way through
oh that's those are that's live wires
august was born with bilateral clubbed
feet
the condition that i had but on both
sides
you know the science has changed a lot
and they're able to do treatments to
correct it
but sitting there as a father you know
looking at my son
my motivation for building bionic limbs
came from thinking about the world that
i want him to grow up in
the beach
[Music]
you know i think it's 2019 and it's
about time we got robots on people
one hope coming out of this lab is that
the work we're doing allows us to push
the capabilities of what the human body
is even capable of doing
so that at some point you know it's not
just i feel so bad that you lost your
limb
here's some prosthesis it's more like oh
i lost my limb cool look what i can do
now
i can upgrade that limb as i get older i
can change all the functionality of it i
have
so much more capability now that i have
this new
robotic extension of my body
the things that we're developing now
that the prototype that i'm wearing
today
is just the beginning
i don't think it's ever going to stop
it's not about
building something that does x and i can
just move on from there
it's going to be a constant exploration
throughout the course of my life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
we used to think that the brain
controlled all our movements so
when you had a spinal cord injury if you
lost that communication between the
brain and spinal cord it's really
nothing you can do
unless you regenerate that connection
it turns out the spinal cord has much
more
of a sophisticated role than we thought
before
we can stimulate the neural networks in
the spinal cord
we can help the spinal cord relearn how
to do things
i was able to do before injury
i was supposed to be an individual that
was going to live and die from this
chair
i mean with the epidural stimulator it's
so close to the point of just move this
leg
you're growing the ability to recovery i
really think
that it's going to give me the
availability to get out of this chair
[Music]
growing up we started out with go-karts
and then we got into bicycles and
everything
my grandpa took me to my first
supercross race seen that and stealed me
with this
want that that's what i wanted to do my
career was at the point where i was
amateur pro it was a couple races and
then i had my pro points where then i
could race the stuff that you see on tv
i went out i was testing a new
motorcycle that i just got
and it was uh like a hundred foot jump
right off the face of that jump i
remember the motor just locked up
it had me pinned and then it just
can just tumble tumble tumble and some
people came up to me like you know you
okay and i'm like
no i don't think so can you get up i was
like no
you're paralyzed from the waist down
your complete injury
you can't feel anything you're not going
to regain any mobility any function
from here on out you're going to have to
have daily care more than likely
you're going to live from a wheelchair
just that was a lot to swallow
basically how i took it was that from
that point on my life was
starting to end versus it continuing to
be an adventure
that was how it felt to me
[Music]
when i got that prognosis the first
thing i went to was looking at
centers that offered rehab and locomotor
training
and which were the top ones that was
where i kind of heard through the
grapevine that they had a guy in
louisville
that was going through the procedure for
the epidural stimulator
and they were seeing some very
interesting things happen
we were doing a series of experiments we
implanted
an individual with the epidural
stimulator
he was laying down and he on his own
tried to move voluntarily he tried to
move his toes and he wiggled his toe
i said holy [ __ ]
we did not anticipate that we tested it
the stimulator off
and they cannot move when you turn this
thing later on
they're able to move this dude's got a
got a switch that just makes it normal
that's how it was making me perceive it
our whole theory about how the motor
system works
was challenged
[Music]
so the traditional way of thinking about
a spinal cord injury
is that the brain is the primary
controller
of movement and function
but it turns out the spinal circuitry is
as smart as the brain it can learn it
can remember it can forget
and it can make decisions how we
actually walk
is this circuitry already has in it
the ability to generate patterns to walk
as devastating as a spinal cord injury
is that
circuitry still has the ability to do
that but
it loses what we would call state of
excitability
so the epidural stimulator is an
off-the-shelf
pain stimulator that's used in people
for pain it
has a lead that's placed in the lower
spinal cord
and it generates an electric field so
the stimulator
actually helps those neurons that are
still viable that are still alive
to be able to function like they did
before
it's five days a week two sessions a day
it started with a toe and then it
started with an ankle and then it
started with a leg
12 sessions in i got my first halt of
independence in standing
it's gotten to the point now where it
just happens naturally i just lean
forward on my walker and
think that i want to stand and i stand
in my legs they hold me
when you immediately turn it on you
don't really notice but once you get a
couple volts up it's like you feel the
body charged and ready
when you're trying you feel that go
through your head from your brain down
your spine to that leg
give them some body weight support keep
them balanced
and then people move their legs in a
walking like pattern
that sends the right information about
walking
back to the spinal cord which it's
expecting and because the spinal cord is
smart and it can learn
it starts relearning how to walk again
with that information and the person
thinking about walking
and over time in some people they are
able
to step independently and in two people
walk completely independently from
physical assistance
but just use a walker or canes
to walk over ground
the biggest thing is feeling it because
after injury you feel nothing and when
you execute those movements you feel
them
it's gonna be a really quick move shift
and unload
there you go i exploded a vertebrae
what is known before all this is there's
no way no how
that i'd ever be able to take a step
again but that's wrong
the next step really needs to be to
design one that is very specific for
this use
so the device that we envision is akin
to a smartphone it can be voice
activated says
okay i want to stand now so you have
your stamp program i want to walk now
you have your walk program
it has closed loop feedback the blood
pressure is monitored
do all of this as autonomously as
possible
[Music]
this is not a cure there's not going to
be
a silver bullet for this there's not
anywhere i think in the near horizon
where we're going to completely
regenerate the spinal cord after an
injury
but if we can make an incremental change
in function it improves their
participation in life
one of the things that hits you when
you're in the hospital am i ever going
to get married
you might have kids and at this point
i'm married
and the epidural stimulator program gave
me the ability to stand at my wedding
as soon as she started walking down the
aisle that motion just hit me
like i'm not i don't really cry but man
i was bawling
[Music]
even getting to dance with my mom i mean
that was that was so awesome
and i feel so close to the kids thing
like i know it's
i know it's coming
[Music]
so
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists policy
makers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
defects in retinal genes cause a
devastating form of childhood blindness
gene therapy is really i think at the
forefront of
treating retinal degenerations there are
now
over 20 clinical trials addressing
various diseases in ways that we didn't
really think possible before
having to make a decision on his behalf
has been
a real struggle this treatment
could change our lives this could stop
a truly terrible disease
as we tackle the problem of childhood
blindness this
is going to be a real breakthrough in
our ability to
change the course of the disease in a
way we never thought possible
[Music]
maverick is my firstborn child he has
been
the most amazing child to raise from the
day that he was born
i didn't have a lot of experience with
babies before i had him
but i just noticed that he had a blank
stare
checked his tracking vision and it
was non-existent we
went through all the genetic testing and
it came back positive for
lieber's congenital amaurosis with a
specific genetic
marker of rpe 65.
the cones and the rods in the eyes
don't allow for light perception so
he is legally blind with specifically
low light blindness he also doesn't have
peripheral vision or vision below his
waist
it's almost tunnel vision
i need a parachute
up here is my room
and these are my pillows this is my eye
patch
it has to be the right lighting for him
to see once
the sun goes down his world is
very dark we take him inside turn
on all the lights until it's time for
bed
[Music]
maverick's condition is degenerative
there is no time frame of when the
degeneration will take place
but it is a well-known fact that he will
be completely blind
in later years took his thoughts quite
some time to subside into sense
of fire and sulfur a torched
landscape in december of 2017
the fda approved gene therapy for
maverick specific condition and so we
went
and talked to dr nigel shortly after it
was approved
maverick was six years old when i first
met him and
this family for a long time had
struggled with getting a diagnosis
and then were very excited finally to
hear that there was a treatment
lexterna is a gene replacement therapy
whereby we're delivering a normal
healthy copy
of the rpe 65 gene to patients who have
two defective copies
this medication is a virus which has
essentially been modified so
its only job is to deliver the genetic
material
we deliver this virus with very fine
needle
underneath the retina and then we have a
healthy copy
of a gene that's been missing in the
cells that normally make it
unfortunately with this disease the
cells that absorb the light the
photoreceptors
are constantly degenerating and there
gets to be a point where there simply
aren't enough cells to
function even if we were to deliver that
gene back
so it makes a lot of sense to treat
earlier pediatric patients
young patients when they have those
cells there and just need a normal copy
of the gene to make the protein
and thus function again so treatment
early in children is really
the way to go to achieve the best
results here at children's hospital los
angeles
we've treated 17 patients so 34 eyes
we have data that the treatment effect
is stable without any loss
in function five years ago there were no
treatments for this disease
and for the bulk of retinal
degenerations these patients if they
were lucky got a
diagnosis with genetic testing but
beyond that there wasn't
much that we could do aside from get the
most out of the vision that they have
since the fda approval of lexterna
that's really opened the door to
not just treating this relatively rare
retinal degeneration but
essentially any retinal degeneration
this has been probably the most
difficult decision
that i've ever had to make in my entire
life
it makes me very nervous because it is
so new
if it doesn't go well it's my fault
because i chose to do this to my child
i honestly feel like i hit the jackpot
when i had maverick
i don't know any other seven-year-old
kid
that could handle everything that he has
been through
with such appreciation for life you know
he is willing to
do or try anything
all right here we go after today our
life could potentially change forever
[Music]
love you
he might go back home and for the first
time have fun with his friends by the
pool as it's getting dark
ride his bike at dusk go
trick-or-treating these are the sort of
improvements that really
change a child's life and the motor
confidence that comes with
ambulating and interacting with the
environment in a way that they couldn't
before i think really has lifelong
[Music]
consequences
[Music]
okay
[Music]
it takes seven days for the corrected
dna to be absorbed
so at seven days he could potentially
see again
[Music]
it just comes in very small doses
and it could take up to four months they
said
[Music]
maverick had his two surgeries
and we are home the first day
that i really noticed that something was
different was riding in a car
and he said mom i'm just looking outside
and i'm seeing what is outside the
windows like i've never been able to see
through the windows
seemed so small but it was really
life-changing for him to be able to look
out
of a window ready okay listen to me
one more game of tag maverick sit
ready one more game one two three
four five
in the past seven years we don't even
come in the backyard at night this is
it's a true miracle you cannot stop
me
okay i got maverick
willow come here get him
[Music]
he has a whole new level of independence
and he is ready to conquer
anything that is given to him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everything i do comes from seeing
patients and not having an answer for
how to help them
right now all of us are using mobile
technologies and computers
for typing and texting and sending
messages
generating language folks with locked in
syndrome don't have any way to do that
gregory had brain damage i don't think
he'll ever be able to do this
and dr melanie said it is rewiring
his brain he'll be able to do it
it was astounding to me it will be real
fun to see where this goes
it's almost science fiction
when the phone rang at eight o'clock in
the morning
and it was the hospital and they told me
i needed to get there right away
they found out it was
a brain stem major stroke
gregory lost his speech
he lost the use of his body limbs he was
instantly paralyzed and his speech was
taken
and we were given that it was locked in
syndrome
and i had no never heard of it didn't
know anything about it
and i remember leaving the hospital that
day
not understanding at all but thinking
that greg's body was dead but his brain
was alive
and how um horrific that was
i'm 100 dependent on my caregivers i am
bathed i have range of motion
i am dressed i have to have finished
with my breakfast and wait two hours
before i can be laid down for range of
motion or any physical movement
i'm physically put into my wheelchair
with a hoyer lift and my caregivers help
i'm a tube feeder no liquid or food
enters my mouth i would be at risk of
getting aspiration pneumonia
it frustrates me when people ignore me i
may have something to say and they will
not look me in the face or ask me if i
have something i want to say
it frustrates me when people act like i
am deaf they talk around me to each
other but not to me
they don't include me in on the
conversations it frustrates me when
people ask the people around me
questions that i can answer
as if i weren't there
my name is dr melanie freed oaken
i am a professor at oregon health and
science university in portland oregon
so we do have a full agenda for the hour
today
mostly something from every team so
let's start
with software and look at pivotal
tracker
our team is unique we have four
different teams that together
have worked for 12 years to develop our
non-invasive brain computer interface
i am a speech language pathologist i
work primarily on our brain computer
interface research projects
our brain computer interface technology
is primarily aimed at people with
very severe disabilities locked in
syndrome is a
term that we use to describe someone who
is essentially locked into
his or her body the kind of classic form
of locked in syndrome involves
only eye movement or blinking but
there's also
complete lis where the person has lost
all of their voluntary motor function so
even the ability to blink
or to move the eyes is is lost if you
have no voluntary motor function you
have no way to communicate
with another human being so that's the
the gap that we're trying to fill
a lot of the brain computer interface
work is being done
in engineering labs or neuroscience labs
with graduate students and researchers
and has not been tried
we take our work out into the community
and we work with many individuals with
severe disabilities
hey there greg nice to see you
doing well today good
good to hear it brain computer interface
allows someone to control a computer
just using only their brain waves in our
system we have an electrode cap that
holds electrodes against the scalp
and they can watch what the system is
presenting to them
lift his head up a little bit so that i
can slide the cap on
okay are you ready to go okay so it'll
be this is fun
here we go
there's one letter presented at a time
in the middle of the screen
so it's just flash flash flash letter
letter letter
you're watching that stream of letters
go by and when you see the letter you
want
you have that involuntary brain response
of yes
that one instead of
someone moving their hand to press the
letter
m they're looking at a screen and when
they see the letter m
they get a special brainwave a surprise
brainwave
that's called the p300 and that p300
brainwave
is being taken as their keystroke
i have tested various programs created
by the engineers of computer programmers
to see if they are computer friendly for
people like me
the exercises i do on the computer are
challenging and i like being challenged
[Music]
all right
nice job that was awesome
the kind of general wisdom in the bci
field right now is that it typically
works for
healthy users under controlled
situations
you know our rsvp keyboard works
reliably for
most healthy people who try it but when
we take it out into the field
it's less likely to work
american legion in portland oregon
and the gregory out there tonight
the pie in the sky you know the dream
goal for brain computer interface would
be to allow
people with severe disabilities and and
communication impairments to communicate
in real time that's really not possible
with any
kind of assistive technology for
communication at this point
um obviously we want to make it faster
make it better that's what we're working
towards but
the first goal is to make it work
consistently and reliably for the people
who need it
i have had people be fearful to approach
me
i would want them to know that i'm not
contagious
i would want them to know it's okay to
approach me and talk
i would want them to know i have a sense
of humor i would want people to never
have to experience what i go through
daily
locked-in syndrome is not for sissies
i am excited to be on board for whatever
this new technology takes
us i'm happy to be part of the team
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the destruction of natural ecosystems is
one of the biggest threats to our planet
whether through climate change natural
events or human interference
we are losing vital habitats areas like
forests or coral reefs not only harbor
millions of species
but they provide valuable ecosystem
services
benefits us humans gain from nature
thankfully people across the planet are
working to restore them
in some instances fire is as important
to a forest as water and the sun
it can release valuable nutrients
clearing space for light
stimulating new growth but in areas like
the american northwest
increasingly warmer and drier climates
are changing how
and if forests can recover this fire
here is the williams flats fire
they had about 45 000 acres burn and you
can just see
what the burn looks like after it goes
through and how there's just nothing
left
normally you'd have uh low severity
fires go through
and the tops of these crowns would have
all kinds of cones ready to open up and
drop seeds
because these fires are so large and
massive due to increased temperatures
from climate
change there's just nothing left here
grant canary runs drone seed and hopes
the tech startup from seattle
can make a difference the mission of our
company is to make reforestation
scalable
for the purpose of making a dent in
carbon emissions now how do you do that
utilizing drone swarms
droneseed surveys the land using 3d
laser scanning technology known as lidar
this gives them a huge number of data
points which they use to build a
detailed map of the area
we run software to then identify the
obstacles off of that 3d terrain map
we actually get a point cloud of about
800 000 points per second
most like lidar and self-driving cars is
around 200 000 points per second
so it's incredibly dense we're able to
identify these microsites where
seed vessels will grow really well
[Music]
the software then plans out all of the
missions for the aircraft and so it's
exactly what you expect if you were like
planning out
like how to mow your lawn it's a
lawnmower pattern that goes back and
forth in different areas
the operator controls take off and
landing once the drone is airborne ai
takes over to fly the predetermined
route
we put about a thousand seed vessels per
acre
each one of those has somewhere between
four to six seeds
in it a human planter can do about
two acres a day maybe three
drones we're targeting 20 to 40
depending upon the terrain
according to canary it can take two
years to grow trees in a nursery
which is time these forests just don't
have if these areas are left without
having trees planted immediately after a
fire
invasive species quickly move in
changing the landscape
and making growth of trees much harder
the big risk is
is this going to transform and turn into
step or savannah
and it's going to come back as 10 foot
tall shrubs as far as like mitigating
the worst effects of climate change
there's really a handful of things you
can do
the best one is planting trees because
they are the most efficient thing you
can do to sequester carbon
just as forests are vital ecosystems on
land
so are coral reefs in the ocean
they're home to a quarter of all marine
life despite making up less than 0.1
percent of the ocean
they protect land from storms and waves
and provide valuable resources
such as the fish we eat but reefs are in
decline thanks to overfishing and
climate change
half of all reef systems have already
been destroyed
scientists predict that in the next
30 years if we not do anything
more than 95 percent of the coral reef
around the world will be in dangerous
on a small island 140 kilometers from
bangkok
a team of biologists are working on ways
to restore coral reefs
damaged by global warming
the ocean absorbs much of the heat
trapped by greenhouse gases
since 1993 the rate of ocean warming
has more than doubled the highest
temperature that we got
was 34 centigrades and that
makes many corals in thailand
bridge and eventually die when stressed
by conditions such as temperature change
corals expel the symbiotic algae that
gives them their distinctive colours
a process known as bleaching the algae
lives inside the coral for protection
and in return uses photosynthesis to
help feed the coral
if a coral is severely bleached the
chances of disease and death
increase the important thing that we
have to make sure
is that the baby coral that we produce
they have
to be able to withstand to the changes
of the environments
professor chowanich's work is centred on
growing resilient coral
one way she believes is to improve the
coral's genetics
ciao niche and her team have developed
artificial fertilization techniques on a
mass scale
during the spawning season between
january and march they collect eggs and
sperm from several coral colonies
and bring them up on land to fertilize
in their hatchery
here the larvae are grown on concrete
plates in tubs full of seawater
they're kept in the hatchery for two
years so they're strong enough and then
replanted by hand on the sea floor
the baby coral that we produce they have
high diversity of genetics and these can
help them to survive in a changes
environments
funding issues mean the hatchery doesn't
have reliable air conditioning
running water or perfect lab conditions
but in a twist of fate
the crude facilities might just have
helped the baby corals
so usually the temperature of the water
in hatchery
is higher than normal about two degrees
centigrade our hot chili is like a
one star hotel resting the coral in this
one star hotel
actually make our baby baby corals
stronger
and can withstand the real temperature
when we release them back to the oceans
the team have grown about 10 000 corals
so far
corals with this genetic diversity have
a survival rate of at least
50 percent while the natural survival
rate is just
0.01 but the success comes at a cost
100 for each coral replanted
in recent years mass coral bleaching
events have happened all over the world
from hawaii to australia the gulf of
mexico
madagascar and the maldives but projects
like this in thailand show there's hope
for our delicate ecosystems
start to see more fish more animals like
crab and trims are coming to the areas
using our corals as a habitat
as a home
[Music]
though far in 2019 weather and climate
events killed more than 4 000 people
globally
and caused around 42 billion dollars in
insured losses
scientists widely agree it's only
getting worse
replenishing habitats like forests and
reefs are vital in ensuring the health
of our planet
reversing climate change and protecting
us from its disastrous effects
for most illnesses a vaccine is an
almost guaranteed lifeline
but influenza is different we have very
good measles vaccine we have a very good
bella vaccine very good mumps vaccine
all of these viruses in the population
haven't changed over the last 50 60
70 years in contrast influencer
changes every year
vaccines are critical but they're only
around 50 percent effective
because they don't fight every strain of
flu here we are
so scientists around the world are
searching for a shot that fights
different strains of the virus
including some that might not even exist
yet it's really very exciting because we
know that
you are working for something good it
may change the whole
world and the health of many people this
breakthrough would give us lasting
protection against influenza
but it might also help us understand how
we get there with other viruses
too
the horseshoe crowd it's a living fossil
that has called earth its home
for almost half a billion years it's
outlived dinosaurs and survived mass
extinctions and ice ages
but today it's facing a new threat their
adaptations have worked with the way the
earth has changed and it's only in
recent years
with the with humans bringing impacts to
their population that they've started to
have declines
rising sea levels habitat loss and over
harvesting
all threaten the population but if
you've ever had a vaccine
injection or a medical implant then you
might not know that you've been relying
on this prehistoric creature's blood to
save your life
now after decades of waiting a new
synthetic solution could change
here on our beaches on the delaware bay
it is a place that people
are witnessing a phenomena that they
cannot see anywhere else it's the
equivalent of the wildebeests crossing
the serengeti
in may and june here on the delaware bay
where we are right now
millions of crabs come out on a high
tide
lay their eggs about six inches deep in
the sand and they will stay
in the sand and hatch in about a month
and horseshoe crab eggs
are a really critical part of the
ecosystem here
if a single crab is laying almost 100
000 eggs
that is providing a food source for
shorebirds
for gulls for fish for terrapins
and then all up the food chain for that
and then what happens with the horseshoe
crabs then
trickles down to the whole ecosystem
here
they just have managed to evolve with
the
changing oceans and the changing land
the reason this crab has been able to
evolve for so long
it's blue blood
this copper-based blood contains special
cells called amoebocytes
which are extremely sensitive to
endotoxins these are contaminants
released from the cell walls of harmful
bacteria
and they can cause life-threatening
fever or toxic shock
as soon as the amoebocytes detect any of
these endotoxins
the blood clots around the intruder
immobilizing it
and protecting the crab from infection
in the 1960s
scientists found a way to harness this
unique superpower to make sure our
medical supplies were free from
contamination
and it replaced slower more
unpredictable tests involving rabbits
the formula is called limulus amoebocite
lysa or
lal and relies on amoebocytes taken from
horseshoe crab blood
and so every year half a million crabs
are collected along the atlantic coast
as well as across the eastern shores of
mexico and china
a third of the crab's blood is drawn
before they're released back into the
ocean
it's estimated that 15 percent of crabs
collected die as a result of this
bleeding process
which could mean the loss of 75 000
crabs in the u.s every year
an alternative was found however almost
20 years ago here in singapore
in the past say 20 30 years ago we
managed to collect 30 pieces
in one afternoon but now
it is difficult to find even a few
in the mid 1980s professor ding jek ling
needed lal for work involving ivf
embryos
but there was a problem singapore
research was not very well funded
so because the lal was so expensive we
had to find
a good way to understand how the hustle
crab
blood works so
my research collaborator also my husband
together with our research students went
to the crunchy mud flats
to look for horseshoe crabs and to bring
a few samples back to the lab
we cleaned them we tagged them and we
took only a small
volume of the blood isolating the blood
cells from the hospital crab
and we could produce our own equivalent
of lal
this synthetic equivalent is called
recombinant factor c
and it's a clone of the main gene in a
horseshoe crab's blood which is
sensitive to bacterial endotoxins
it was a moment of realization that
it's going to change the biomedical
industry
and it's going to save a very very
highly threatened
species
[Music]
but pharmaceutical companies didn't come
around as quickly as professor ding had
hoped and so years and then decades
passed
we're a highly regulated industry and to
say we would like to market a new
medicine
a lot of people are reluctant to take a
chance on on trying something new
that's until a scientist at
pharmaceutical company eli lilly with a
particular hobby came along
birding is a hobby of mine so to go to
delaware bay and see the horseshoe crab
spawning
it kind of put it all together for me so
the
horseshoe crab is a keystone species in
its ecology
obviously for its own sake but then for
a lot of other animals that depend on it
if we use rfc then
then there aren't any crabs that are
affected whether it's mortality or
whether there's some behavioral effect
by taking by taking the blood studies
have shown that the rfc
test is a more effective and a
potentially cheaper solution than lal
changing minds however remained the
biggest challenge
there's been several times i was i was
ready to throw in the towel
so it's been it's been a difficult
journey
to fight internally to fight externally
nobody likes change
but we think we're doing it for the
right reasons
we have had success and we do we have
the data at the end of the day
persistence paid off and in 2018 the
first drug to use the recombinant factor
c
test was approved by the fda and eli
lilly is planning to transition 90
of its tests to the synthetic by the end
of 2020.
i think the consequence if industry
carries on
with bleeding crabs at some point there
won't be any so
there are real impacts to what we're
doing and the longer we say oh
you know they'll be available forever
it's it's
likely not true it is important
that we as humans are playing a role in
protecting biodiversity and not
impacting biodiversity the synthetic
version of the horseshoe crab
lysate used by pharmaceutical industry
is going to have a major impact
on horseshoe crab conservation it's not
the only factor that we need we also
need to continue
with harvest limits and with beach
restoration
but reducing the need to
harvest crabs for the use of their blood
will have a major impact
coming up on quick take the lead global
leaders mark earth day 2021 with a
renewed focus on reducing pollution
president biden tries to retake the lead
with a bold pledge
then paris to berlin by train in just an
hour
that could be the future of
transportation and a greener planet
we're talking to the ceo of virgin
hyperloop live about the latest progress
and will the world continue to say
cheers to wine and spirits
after the pandemic we'll take a look at
some big wins and trends in this
industry
it is thursday april 22nd i'm scarlett
fu and i'm madison mills those stories
and more coming up on quick take the
lead
[Music]
happy earth day everyone leaders from 40
nations today
joined president biden for a virtual
summit on climate change biden seeking
to re-establish the us as a major player
on the climate stage
pledging in his opening remarks to cut
the country's greenhouse gas emissions
by half
and boosting aid to developing nations
we can solve this crisis on our own as i
know you all fully understand
all of us all of us and particularly
those of us who represent
the world's largest economies we have to
step up
so here to help us understand what this
renewed commitment really entails beyond
just stepping up
is bloomberg news power and renewable
energy editor will wade
will great to see you on quick take
biden made some specific promises
a 50 to 52 reduction in u.s greenhouse
gas emissions over the next decade
and a doubling of aid to developing
countries how does this compare to the
us's previous commitment before trump
came along
and reversed everything it's a whole lot
more ambitious the previous commitment
that obama
pledged when we signed the paris
agreement five years ago
was 26 to 28 reduction so this is double
that
yeah that so it does sound just by those
numbers alone that this is really taking
the us in a new direction
of course this is politics and biden has
a lot of work to do to convince
the rest of government to go along with
him assuming that he can get congress to
back him on this
how exactly or even generally would the
u.s
reach that kind of target 50 to 52 would
it replace
all the gas guzzling suvs with electric
vehicles i mean what kind of federal
and state policy changes would need to
be put into place well there's
several basic strategies the first one
is
a lot more clean energy so right now we
get about
40 percent of our energy from carbon
free sources that's nuclear wind and
solar
i've heard that we need to at least
double that to about 80 percent
um some people talk about even tripling
that and then once we've got
most of our electricity coming from
clean sources that's when we get to
start
that's when we need to start doing more
things with electricity
like shifting from gasoline cars to
electric cars we need a lot more
electric cars on the road
okay so that's uh disrupting a lot of
existing industry
potentially angering a lot of
constituents here
john kerry who of course is the white
house's climate changes are
said that other countries when they
heard joe biden's pledge
immediately questioned whether the u.s
can be trusted to deliver on this
promise
especially since president trump had
pulled the u.s out of the paris
agreement
john kerry made the point that the
private sector is already doing a lot of
the work
is that really the case it is there and
certainly the u.s has a big credibility
gap to make up foreign countries
are rightly skeptical of whether the u.s
is going to put its money where its
mouth is but
even after trump reversed course with a
lot of federal policies
we saw private businesses we saw cities
we saw states come up with all kinds of
policies and strategies for reducing
emissions so even now
we're about halfway to meeting
the obama pledge of 26 we're about 13
down over about half the time so we're
more or less on track
so we're on track so i suppose you could
make the argument that we could get
there
how exactly did president trump's policy
shifts affect u.s emissions
well the first thing was he tried to
roll back a lot of policy
a lot of rules on emit on coal and
air pollution but it didn't have